salut un petit peu comment on avait fait
dans la vidéo du mois dernier le bout ce
brain avec vous sur le thème du mensonge
avec philippe roche on va en faire un
aujourd'hui sur le thème de la mémoire
vous allez essayer de retenir en temps
réel des visages et des prénoms par
exemple la ce visage il s'appelle fabien
j'espère que vous le saviez et si vous
le saviez pas vous pouvez vous abonner
prenez ça parce que c'est à dire un jeu
un test mais ça va vous donner une
mécanique j'espère que vous pourrez
appliquer après dans la vie courante et
soyez concentré ça va vite
certaines personnes ont du mal à retenir
les prénoms des gens est d'associer le
visage à ce prénom c'est peut-être votre
cas et c'est le cas de la personne qui
est avec moi
laetitia de la chaîne le corps la maison
l'esprit on va faire un jeu ensemble ou
laetitia et vous vous allez essayer de
mémoriser sauf que vous avez été un
petit peu plus tard mais puisque je vous
donnais trois des cinq astuces qui sont
dans le chapitre de ce livre sur comment
retenir un visage et un prénom mais
est-ce que fabien et vous a précisé que
moi je suis vraiment vraiment vraiment
pas capable de retenir les visages et
les prénoms des gens c'est d'ailleurs
tout l'intérêt 1 c'est pour ça que c'est
toi que j'ai invitèrent première
technique on va utiliser ses l'attention
la deuxième c'est la mnémotechnique et
le troisième c'est l'imaginaire fait le
même temps qu'elle et vous allez voir à
la fin de la vidéo quand quelques
minutes seulement vous êtes capable de
retenir deux visages et même plus d'air
la tension était déjà en train de
l'appliquer
là forcément de ce que tu es concentré
sur ce qu'on fait il va falloir qu'on
fasse travailler l'imaginaire et la
mnémotechnique pour se rappeler qu'elle
s'appelle julie gayet c'est parfait vous
aussi vous avez qui est julie gayet et
vous savez pourquoi vous connaissez
julie gayet mieux que n'importe quel
autre julie sa cause du scooter
l'histoire des scooters donc tu vas
l'imaginé julie avec un casque de
scooter mais en train de rouler sur un
scooter le suivant il s'appelle
alexandre je te propose donc de
l'imaginer en roi arthur par rapport à
alexandre astier la troisième j'ai envie
que lui met une au real au dessus de la
tête alesi auréolé là au dessus de sa
tête visualiser bien ça parce qu'elle
s'appelle marie alors le suivant pour le
retenir ça va pas être compliqué pour
quoi je vais vous dire pourquoi et donc
je repense à fabian l'écart qui fait
vraiment vraiment vraiment très mal à
nicolas sarkozy c'est ça tu dois le
l'imaginer en train de parler comme
nicolas sarkozy passe suivante c'est
martin alors vous l'imaginez à la plage
à la montagne à la campagne qui fait du
poney ce que vous voulez mais vous
l'associez au livre martine marty dont
tu peux l'imaginer dans un livre tu peux
l'imaginer en train de faire un château
de sable sur une couverture d'un livre
tu essayes de faire est le suivant c'est
facile il s'appelle tiers comme dans le
cross exactement pour ceux qui
connaissent bien youtube on va penser à
pierre cros de ce campus est un petit
air de ressemblance comme ça alors pour
pour pierre cros désole pierre si tu
tombes sur cette vidéo tu vas l'imaginé
avec un bon double menton eh ben j'ai
pensé au doublement de césar c'est lui
qui s'auto rennes dessus et si vous
savez pas qui est pierre cros vous
pouvez imaginer une pluie de cailloux
qui lui tombe sur la tête des pierres
le nombre de super c'est de me refaire
tous les prénoms dans l'ordre la
première c'est qu'il est la première
c'est julie gayet ouais donc elle
s'appelle judy la deuxième
en fait si le roi arthur sauf qui
s'appelle alexandre la troisième si la
meuf qu'on aille
quand un ami ancien c'était marie oui
elle a pris cher le troisième c'était le
nicolas de nicolas sarkozy parce que tu
fais trop mal ça arrive c'est le
quatrième exactement et c'est vachement
mieux quand on sait compter
c'est mieux elle c'est martine que
j'appelais marie-mai s'appelle martin
parce qu'en fait martine à la plage est
confirmée et lui c'est pierre cros donc
s'appelle pierre petite chute
vous avez besoin de retrouver quel était
le prénom de la personne donc le fait de
les avoir appris dans l'ordre maintenant
on va plus de servir à rien là je vais
encore pioché si sa laeticia et vous
allez essayer de deviner en même temps
qu'elle ait essayé de voir combien vous
faites sur six vous me mettrez dans les
commentaires et peut-être ils vont se
battre c'est pas sûr que tout est bon
aussi ça non c'est pas sûr du tout mais
vous êtes un petit peu en battle contre
laeticia
pardon si tu veux alors elle avec son
petit air angélique c'est la meuf quand
même sens exactement c'est marie c'est
vrai ça oui oui je lis et nicolas attend
avec sa tête de gentil s'était c'est un
peu plus d'un pub à oui c'était un tueur
qui en fait apple avec son exact et
mangera est allé à voir faux sur
celui-ci est alors lui bien évidemment
c'est pierre cros dompierre oui le
double menton 70 ans pierre que
peut-être vous vous aviez retenu avec
une chute de cailloux sur la tête en
avait la mairie non non non vallières et
c'est l'autre c'est julie gayet j'étais
en train de refaire un conflit avec elle
c'est la meuf qui a eu 10 minuit dans
une vie dont c'est martin oui je suis
auto épaté mais j'aimerais bien voir ce
que ça donne dans la vraie vie c'est
encore plus simple quand on a la
personne en entier et qu'on les demande
encore plus d'informations et qu'on a le
temps de discuter à tout petit peu ne
serait ce qu'un tout petit peu avec les
deux autres clés que je vous avais pas
donner justement c'est la boucle
phonologique et la répétition évidemment
c'est à dire replacer le prénom au
maximum deux fois au lieu de demander
passez-moi de l'eau s'il vous plaît
dites pas c'est moi de l'eau martin s'il
vous plaît que si la personne s'appelle
martin forcément je sais pas encore
combien vous avez fait si vous avez fait
moins de quatre il est fort possible
qu'il faut travailler un petit peu plus
la tension ou la visualisation comme
vous dites visualise essayer de le faire
réellement j'avais fait une vidéo
d'ailleurs pour ceux qui ont du mal à
visualiser vous remercie laetitia de la
chaîne le corps l'âme et dans l'esprit
d'être venu c'est la deuxième fois que
je la fais venir pour un bout ce brain
sur la mémoire parce que typiquement
c'est une personne qui dit ne pas avoir
de mémoire et qui galèrent donc à chaque
fois je me dis si elle y arrive
elle est si vous y arrivez vous
trouverez un lien vers sachet dans la
description publient du contenu tous les
jours depuis plus de deux ans maintenant
la halle a fait tout un parcours
personnel en inde et en asie
en ce moment ça mélange un peu le voyage
et le développement personnel c'est
hyper intéressant je reçois encore pas
mal de questions sur le lit votre
cerveau est extraordinaire
oubliez pas que j'ai fait une vidéo où
je réponds à toutes les questions c'est
aussi dans la description et le livre
est toujours dispo en librairie fnac
amazon externe avec dédicace le 24 juin
à calligrammes la rochelle et à côté de
caen à mondeville
c'est le 28 juin sa culture et puis je
vous donne un petit rendez vous alors on
prend son papy sus au crayon volvo dans
le téléphone
ce sera mercredi à 17h30 la prochaine
vidéo on parlera d'argent ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]